I vacillated for like 10 seconds
deciding which way I wanted to go and if
I had chosen the street I wouldn't have
seen them and if I had been a second
later
I wouldn't have seen him
when did TV become a major goal for you
so
TV became so I was
kind of peeking around the corner
looking at TV you know starting around
0.708 I mentioned in my book one of my
buddies seat man was a director friend
who had gone from indie films to
television
and so I was like okay like he's a he's
a filmmaker to me you know and he's
going to TV and he's I know him
personally he's a cool guy so maybe
maybe there's something there maybe it's
not the the place where storytellers go
to die because you know in the past
people just TV TV
um
and so
I kind of always have my eye on him and
there's it's funny too because there's
like
I take I'm not a mystical kind of person
but I I I guess I'm spiritual
um and
I often
can't help but remark on like
the the Kismet of events sometimes and I
was walking down Melrose I parked on
Melrose to go somewhere and I was like
oh there's like something shooting and
they had like all their equipment and
like you know blocking this place of
business or whatever I was like do I
want to walk down Melrose or do I want
to walk through the alley behind the
Ally Melrose alley Narrows and I was
like Ally and so I walked down the alley
and out of the corner of my eye I see
the back of his head
oh and and I was like wait you know is
that you are y'all his name and he
turned around I was like yo that's crazy
I haven't seen him in years
um and just like the real like
I vacillated for like 10 seconds
deciding which way I wanted to go and if
I were had chosen the street I wouldn't
have seen him and if I had been a second
later
I wouldn't have seen him wow and then
that time
um this must have been 2012 and he was
like oh well you should um apply for
this HBO directing program so I applied
and I didn't get in but like I got a
little bit closer I had to get a DGA
um uh I had to get a DGA
um
director
recommendation and I was able to kind of
finagle that and I was like okay I'm
kind of getting closer even though I'm
still like on the outskirt and so
um
you know I I applied to every program
that existed and
in 26
no I'm sorry in 2015 after my short that
I made which was called Black Card
premiered at this film festival in New
York that was part of HBO
um
the gentleman who runs the Sony program
Brett King was at the screening and came
up to me and was like you know you
should apply
and I was like all right well you got it
and so of course it was like do for the
next day you know with a
letters of recommendation notary notary
public and like an essay and I was like
cool I've been I've been at the wire
before and um I got into the Sony
program and
the fall of 2015.
and that was when you know around that
time you know if I were
I kind of talked a lot earlier about
expectation and I think you know the
thing
to kind of
take away at least as far as how I think
about it is like
I'll do a thing
I know that it can potentially do all of
these things like maybe help me get into
TV or maybe you know get me an agent or
manager but then I kind of while I know
they exist and while I'll do my best to
put
to
create it in a way that helps me achieve
that then I kind of in my mind back away
from that because I don't want that to
be the
that the only way to put value on what I
do with it and so this short film was
very much that it was like all right I'm
gonna call my active friends I'm gonna
if there's anyone I know that can you
know maybe is more visible as an actor
than somebody else like maybe I'll see
if they'll do me a favor I'll put the
money where it matters on screen you
know
um and in a perfect world it'll help me
get in the TV but also I know that won't
happen that I mean I also know that's
not a guarantee I know it'll be a
guarantee for me to make this short look
at it and say okay this is like where my
talent Lies when no one's telling me
what to do and I'm making it for myself
and so that alone will be something that
I'll really get value from because then
I can learn and pivot again but it did
the thing that I had hoped for and it
got me into these uh it got me on the
radar of of people in
the business of making TV
and so I did the Sony program
2015 I did the HBO program 2016. I did
the Disney ABC program 2016 to 2018 and
I did the uh nbcu program in 20.
16. and through the relationships I was
building I was shadowing on shows
observing other directors and
um you know making sure that I was
building a network of folks who were
aware of me and what my goal was which
was to direct single camera comedy
and sorry just a side note here you
mentioned your book did I just see your
book for a second okay so this is the
book
um you know this photo was actually
taken on one of my return trips from La
back to New York after I moved out here
um and a buddy of mine Eric Van selfden
took it before we got oysters because
that was our ritual
thank you
um but yes transition is a director's
journey in motivational handbook
um and it's you know for me it's the
book
that I wish I could have read along the
Journey of the 17 years to getting paid
for narrative directing and I
distinguished that because I got I made
my own films I did uh client work for
people but that that was never someone
saying we want to hire you to direct
this like narrative
film or narrative TV show
um and and tell our story in this kind
of way with your with your skill set so
um you know it's a mixer of how to
self-help and inspiration and uh I think
it's it's useful for anybody in a
creative field but it's particularly
tailored for directors
you said you wish you'd had that book
yourself when you were just starting out
was there any tough love advice that you
have in that book that you wish somebody
had given you that maybe it doesn't
always sit well but then you think about
it and you're like yeah it applies
[Music]
you know I don't know if
I don't know if there's if I have tough
love in the book you know I think it's
um
I'd have to think about that because I
almost I'm almost compelled to
revisit my definition of tough love but
you know I feel like the
what I found I responded to in the books
that I read was
someone walking me through undeniable
facts
right so and for like for instance like
in the book I talk about going to the
Robert McKee seminar and people have a
lot of opinions on it but on the third
day he walks through or at least when I
took the the course scene by scene
analysis of Casablanca which is one of
my favorite films and so you walk
through it you break it down and then
for me what that did was like well at
the conclusion of this intricate
breakdown
of something where I'm nodding my head
for five hours like that that makes
sense oh that's great that's smart
I can't go back to my script
and
where it doesn't have those things that
I know work I can't say it's good enough
you know what I mean like I have to Now
work on my script and get it to the
point where with where whatever I'm
trying to do with this story matches the
execution of those things in a
Casablanca you know and I think in the
book the things that I talk about are
like you know if we agree that these are
the things then
how do we make sure that we
um
as artists and as business people
execute on those things you know so like
I even talk a lot about like
the technique and the psychology of the
job like it doesn't matter if you make
the best shot list in the world if you
can't navigate the personalities that
come
out of the trailer and out of the office
and out of the van every day then you're
not gonna get one third of that shot
list and nobody's gonna remember what
you had planned
you know so
um
kind of just getting into the
nitty-gritty of that and maybe opening
opening the reader's eyes to those
things more so than like
um
you know maybe that maybe that's my
version of tough love yeah I was gonna
say that that sounds like some
explosions yeah maybe it is I like that
though you know it is I I think of like
Whiplash
yeah like I'm not like you know throwing
throwing cameras at people